Hello Soldiers!
Welcome back!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid!
Please welcome!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Chow, Chow, Chow Mater!
Please!
Wait a second!
There we go.
We can watch, I guess, the intro.
But I want to... I always... I want to talk first.
Vic Boss!
We're not there yet.
We will be there, eventually.
Welcome back.
Today is going to be fun, fun, fun, fun, fun!
We're...
Thank you for joining... Oh my goodness.
Thank you for... It doesn't even let me talk for like 2 seconds.
Thank you for joining on Nemi's charity stream.
Much love.
Thank you!
Kashimoto, thank you so much for the super chat.
I had a lot of fun.
Here, I'm just gonna... Here, we'll watch the intro first and then I'll talk.
The game keeps interrupting me.
We'll talk after.
Oh my god, it's Kaz!
That's my girl!
Yeah, Amanda!
Chico!
We rescued him last time.
Cecile!
Never heard from again.
Stranger!
We
might be seeing some of these today.
Oh, Bali.
That's my boss.
So serious.
Hatsune Miku!
I love the peace.
I love the peace!
Alright.
Oh my gosh, the intro.
I love the new theme.
I can't get over it.
And my favorite of all, lively dead maid.
Would that be my Kojima name?
How was the audio by the way?
I didn't check at all when I was playing.
I did not look.
Good?
It's okay?
Okay.
Cool.
Cool, cool, cool.
Peace Walker is one of my most favorite games.
Me too!
I love Peace Walker.
I feel it's a little underrated in the Metal Gear sphere.
But it's so good.
Oh my gosh, it's for real.
It's always up there whenever I talk about my favorite Metal Gear games.
It's so, so good.
Oh, it's so, so good.
Everything about it, I love it.
Yeah.
There would be no V without PW.
Exactly, exactly.
I mentioned this in pre-chat.
I probably should have been doing the extra missions in Peace Walker.
To like get through those off stream.
But instead, I've just been playing a bunch of Ground Zeroes.
I don't know, I just had this itch to play Ground Zeroes again.
And so I've just been doing it.
Because when I get, when we finish Peace Walker and we do Ground Zeroes.
I was like...
So how I want to do it is...
I want to do the main mission, obviously.
And then there's two...
No, sorry, three other missions that I want to do.
I feel like we could do it all in one stream.
Probably.
But um...
Yeah.
So...
Whenever I talk about Metal Gear series, I really go silent when this part of the convo comes up.
I guess I can only...
Is that about what I talked about last week?
But uh...
There's three missions that I want to do in Ground Zeroes.
And I unlocked two of them yesterday.
Because you have to get some special stuff.
You have to do some extra things to unlock them.
So I did that yesterday.
While watching Nemi Nightmare.
So...
Yeah, Peace Walker...
Not Peace Walker, sorry.
Ground Zeroes is like super duper...
We can do it super duper easily.
I say easily, I'm probably setting myself up for failure there.
We can do it super duper quickly.
I think one of the missions...
I'm purposefully not doing them off stream.
I'll do them on stream.
Though I know about them.
But I have not done them before.
So it will be my first time playing them.
I was on Nemi's stream yesterday.
She did her 8 hour charity stream for Little Bean.
And I was there.
We played Age of Empires together.
And oh my gosh, it was actually our first time talking in a voice call together.
So when she called me, I was like...
Nemi Nightmare is...
She's in my ears.
I can hear her directly.
So it was really special.
And I was really nervous.
But she was so cute.
And I was happy.
I'm always happy when I get to collab with my Oshies.
So now I've played Age of Empires 2 with two of my Oshies.
I don't know how this keeps happening.
I hope Nemi didn't scare you away with the Dota talk.
No!
Actually I'm catching flack.
I've seen some people clipping.
And I saw some people posting it on Twitter.
And I saw people being like...
Wow, how does that other girl not know what Dota is?
And I'm like...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, I have TASTE!
No, I'm just kidding.
But I don't know MOBA at all.
I don't do anything like that.
I don't know.
I had a weird dream where...
Sorry, I'm reading an old super chat.
I had a weird dream where all the VTuber idols went to war.
And I was dressed up as Snake fighting Doki dressed up as Liquid.
It's weird because you're usually Venom Snake.
I don't want to be Venom Snake.
I'd rather be Solid Snake.
I only chose Venom for my Twitter profile.
Because...
It's funny.
Thank you for not knowing about MOBAs.
This is why you're my OC.
You know, I have other garbage tastes in games.
And...
Yeah, so...
It all works out, right?
Everybody's got to have their guilty pleasure, you know?
Mine is what we're playing today.
Actually, I'm going to scoot down just a tad.
And...
Come on guys, she plays Chillas.
Yeah, bad horror games are my guilty pleasure.
You're not guilty?
I'm 100% guilty.
I admit that.
One second.
There we go.
Metal Gear Solid and Ace Combat over Dota.
Good game on AoE too, by the way.
So many people just crumble when they get attacked, but you held the fort until the elephants arrived.
I tried!
Why does this keep happening to me?
Why do the enemies keep coming to me?
It's like I have a sweet blood or something.
The little mosquitoes keep coming to me.
Why?
Did you name your cat Paz because of Paz Tapes?
What?
Was Nuke the cat ever an option?
Will I
ever play MGS Survival?
I want to, actually.
I want to because...
Because...
There was...
No, there is...
There is a guy I know.
His name is Fingers.
He actually helped with music for Freak or Treat.
The game that I made.
And he likes Survive.
So I want to get him and Berry Bug and Maddy.
I want us to all do a group.
And he teaches us how to play Survive to the optimal ability.
So, yeah.
Fingers mentioned.
Yeah.
How to survive, survive.
So, load game.
Did
you see?
There is a new maid coming soon.
Crony is finally getting a maid outfit.
Nice.
Okay.
So we built Mother Base.
Up a little.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for all the superchats, you guys.
I took my cat to the vet for a checkup.
She was mad.
How do your cats handle the vet?
They are usually fine after I take them, but they don't like...
Neither of my cats like riding in the car or being in the crate or anything.
If an enemy makes you think about Dota, you can get her to play MGS.
That's only fair.
Maybe.
She said so herself.
She's not a retro...
She's not a retro streamer.
Yeah, do I have any gifts?
I sure hope so.
Inbox!
It's okay.
So let's check out our...
Our people.
Yeah, I got a million...
A million fan letters and gifts from everybody.
I got so many.
A ton of them.
They're all from Big Boss.
He said you're my number one soldier.
He said you're the coolest and prettiest and smartest and strongest.
Hold on, I'm reading the note right now.
And did I mention cutest and funniest and most awesomest soldier on Mother Base?
I couldn't have Mother Base without you.
You are the glue that holds us together.
You are the blood to my mosquito.
Thank you for being here, Mint Phantom.
Love, Big Boss.
And then there's a kissy mark.
We meet the legendary staff member.
Yeah, we gotta meet Leech.
Leech Walker.
Alright, let's just get into it, I suppose.
Yeah, he put on his finest lipstick for this letter.
Monster Hunter Connections is how I got some friends and Oshis to consider playing Metal Gear Peace Walker because of co-op.
Really?
But you also just gotta play it, no?
Ducky, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Yeah, I should have done these.
I should have done these.
I should have done these off stream.
What's wrong with me?
Dab chick.
Oh my gosh, I forgot about dab chick.
Marksmanship challenge.
Let's do target practice to get me back into that.
Oh my gosh, the little guns is a treat.
Why are you yelling at me, Master Miller?
Gosh.
Oh my gosh, Jack.
Welcome to membership.
Did Big Boss also practice kissing paper?
Probably.
Mint is cute and funny.
Thanks.
Mission prep.
Yeah, this is fine.
Alright.
It's fine, it's fine.
I just gotta practice.
Listen up, for us there is no victory.
He's so concise.
He's so...
Thank you.
I don't...OK, hold on.
Yeah, there we go.
Let's do that, baby.
Bing bong.
Where is it?
Oh, you.
Sorry.
Bing bong.
No, there is one right here.
What are you talking about?
Headshot, headshot, headshot.
Barely scraped by.
Oh no.
Oops, shoot, shoot.
I'm hugging him.
Bing bong.
This guy?
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Where are they?
There's more?
I heard one.
Oh my gosh.
Dang, I got him.
Not really.
Anyone else?
Want a piece of me?
There he is.
Where?
Codename Big Phantom.
Thank you.
Over here?
Oh, I think I have to climb up.
I'm so silly.
You always do the target range one?
Yeah, I thought that's what this was.
Boss.
Boss, I'm lost.
Boss, where do I climb?
No, just kidding.
Good luck with the target window.
Thank you!
Is there a ladder?
On the other side?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I thought it would be... Oh my gosh.
I thought it would be like against the wall.
You know what I mean?
Bing bong.
I've been a little spoiled because I've been playing Ground Zeroes with my mouse.
And guys, I get crazy headshots.
I'm just letting you know I'm kind of cracked.
I'm kind of insane.
Dang it.
I'm kind of awesome.
Dang it!
So close!
I know they're headshots too because I get like a little thing that says new long range headshot.
I know it's a headshot too.
It says you got a headshot.
Oh there you are.
Right in the mouth.
Made him look like that.
Boom, headshot.
Kind of.
That was like a cheek shot.
But the front cheek.
Not the back cheek.
Nice.
You hit all the targets in your booth.
Move on to the next one.
Okay.
What's the next one?
Oh there it is.
I see him.
I got you.
We're going to get right in the center.
Nice.
You hit all the targets in your booth.
Move on to the next one.
That's it though, right?
What do you mean the next one?
There's more?
I think I've done enough practice.
No?
I think we're good.
What's the goal of this game right now?
Oh this is what I'm doing at this current moment?
Practice.
Thank you for the superchat!
Good luck getting into Metal Gear.
You better hold your promise.
You better actually be serious if that's why you're not watching.
You better give me a progress report.
You better say... There's something else here.
Kaz, what are you talking about?
Okay, I'm leaving.
Training exercise complete.
Alright.
Clear rank.
Infinity.
There's a free camo in the target practice.
One for folks.
What?
Seriously?
There is?
Not bad Minto.
Thanks.
There is?
Number one?
Target practice one.
Which is this?
Oh this is the...
Should we make a room?
I love that he...I love that he calls it a special treat.
He knows it so well.
As a special treat.
Anybody wanna target practice with me?
Global.
Okay.
Come on in.
I'm just gonna start.
Oh, just kidding.
Yeah, it's fine.
Protect the boss?
It's a shooting range.
Should be fine though.
Can we...Is there friendly fire?
Is there friendly fire?
Can you guys be my...my practice?
I told my bank a secret about you but it got out all over town.
Turns out there were a lot of tellers.
How dare!
Loose lips sink ships.
And banks.
I dug a big hole underneath the bank.
And it will sink.
In two days time.
Oh, pink bag!
When you're done, head over to the exit.
Alright everybody!
Are you okay?
Let's see.
Wait.
Hold on.
Wait, how do I...That's auto-aim.
How do I fight again?
Oh gosh.
Hold on.
How do I do CQC?
It sounds like he's saying make out.
Make out.
Wait, I don't...Oh gosh.
Group A.
No.
How do I...Gosh, sorry guys.
I'm trying to remember how to CQC.
Oh, RT.
Do it.
Why isn't it not working?
Sneak in.
Sneak out.
That's so funny.
Press and hold RT.
That's what I'm doing.
Why isn't it working?
Sneak in.
Sneak out.
This is so stupid.
Why is there a training?
When is it going to turn on?
Commence!
When does it turn on?
Oh!
Let's turn it on!
Hey, hold on!
I'm gonna get the most.
Oh, nobody got it.
Gonna get the most.
I'm gonna get the most.
I got him.
Why does he disappear?
Oh, shoot.
He's right in front of me, isn't he?
Wait, I can't see anything.
Why can't I see anything?
What changed?
I can't see anything.
Also, why am I... Oh, I'm in auto-aim, that's why.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm embarrassing.
Me!
Uh-oh.
Oh, oop.
Me!
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
Yeah.
Me!
Oh, where'd he go?
Oh!
Stop being so fast!
No, stop being so fast!
I'm on... I'm on tilt controls!
Hey.
Hey, you all, you never miss if you just spam it.
Oh, my bad.
I killed a person.
Was the Geneva Convention invented now?
Probably not.
Come
on, guys!
Spray and pray!
Yes, it was.
Oh.
After the end of World War II, the world was split in two.
Spray and pray!
Oh, oops.
Sometimes there are worthy sacrifices.
Like the people that stand in our way.
Spray and pray!
When is it over?
I got him and I didn't kill an innocent person with it too.
Oh, come on.
Let me have him!
Hey!
You took my bed!
What?
You took my target and he was for me.
Are you gonna die?
Alright, is this never ending?
How long does this...
Wait, hold on.
Let me get the...
Where is the camo?
This area looks so familiar.
You missed!
How could you miss?
Don't die on me.
I got a T-shirt!
T-shirt up here everybody!
Come get your T-shirt!
Free T-shirt!
Free MSF T-shirt!
Get your T-shirt!
You're welcome!
Alright.
Alright, that's enough practice everybody.
I can't...
I'm not...
I have to be supervised on the base.
Shot in the head.
Thanks guys.
Lay there!
No, no, no, no!
Lay there on the ground.
Come here!
No!
Alright!
You're laying on the ground.
Alright, come on.
Let's go.
No!
Let's play the game!
You've got to wait for backup before going any farther.
Come on!
It's not over yet.
It is over.
Training exercise complete.
Thanks boss.
You're welcome.
Awesome.
Good job team.
Sorry, I was getting kind of into the shooting the targets.
I thought that there would...
I thought it would stop eventually and then give us a score.
No!
We had no camaraderie.
We had none!
Sad.
Alright, are you guys ready to play the actual game?
That was so funny.
OK.
Classic wisp behavior.
We are about to destroy the barricade.
We need C4 charges.
Oh yeah, that's right!
Oh gosh.
That's right.
What was the license plate of the truck?
I don't remember.
This is Mint Streams.
I go to check the mail and my Mint merch arrived!
Yay!
Thank you for getting it.
Thank you so much.
Oh shoot.
I just realized I forgot to do something.
I should be fine.
I'll fix it later.
It's nothing for you to worry about.
C4!
Thank you!
OK, obviously I'm gonna host.
Anybody can come in.
Mission prep.
Let's see.
Let's get our... would it be under weapons or items?
It's there, the C4.
C4.
Kiwi!
Burgoby.
Burgboy.
I'm gonna call you Gurbo... Burgoby.
Alright, you got your C4?
You have your C4?
What's the T-shirt look like?
How can one man...
How can one man look so good in a T?
Go with the T.
Oh my god, get this man a bra!
Wow!
Oh, he's so casual.
I love casual Friday.
OK, anyway.
With this Uniqlo drip.
Oh my gosh!
That would have been so cool to have the Uniqlo shirts in the games.
Missed opportunity for real.
Ready?
Ready Burgoby?
Burgoby, Gurboby, Burgoby.
They were?
They were DLC?
I don't remember them.
I can't remember all the camos.
Available.
Wait, which ones could you get for this game?
Could you get the one...
The white T-shirt with boss on the back?
The boss art?
That's my favorite Peace Walker shirt.
Actually...
Was there more than...
Yes, there were several Peace Walker shirts.
Because there was the one with Strange Love.
Oh no!
Burgoby, I only brought...
Shh, come here.
Shh, I have a secret.
I only brought...
I only brought weapons to kill.
What do I do?
I thought
I drank a gun, but I didn't.
That's...
What are you doing?
Okay.
Oopsie.
Oh.
It's all up to you.
I'll get the law ready.
You got this guy.
Oh, you got him.
You got him.
Burgoby, it's all up to you.
I...
Oh, we're taking him home.
Take him home.
Wait.
Oh, I need...
I gotta equip it.
I'm stupid.
Oh, you took him home.
Good job.
Burgoby, should I use the law?
Bert told me you operate on Xbox.
I would offer my assistance, but I'm sick and monsters need hunting.
Oh.
Have fun with hunting!
You can do that in this game too.
I'm just saying.
But feel better also.
Oh, you got his ass.
Nice.
I'm gonna take him home.
He keeps stealing my thunder.
I keep hearing the beep.
It's kind of freaking me out.
I'm taking him home.
Here he comes.
There he goes.
At neck-breaking speed.
We're good?
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Let's go.
I am the law.
Meow.
Oh, I see a guy up there.
You wanna take him out?
You got him.
Easy.
Don't miss.
Wow.
Nice one.
Nice shot.
Wish we could grab him though.
No pressure.
Any other men?
Any other guys?
Wait, which way do we go?
Is there not a guy that's like wandering around over here?
There's some down here, no?
Yep, there's one.
What if I...
Okay, if you don't, I will.
You got this.
Oh, you want me to?
Okay.
You got this.
Oh.
One.
Ooh.
Oh, I was gonna give you the three, Borgobi!
I was gonna give you the three!
You barely made it.
Oh, there's another guy.
I'll take care of him.
He probably sucked.
Ripped that guy.
If he were stronger, he would be alive and then we could take him.
Yeah!
Yay!
It's this way, right?
Wait, west.
Borgobi, which way is west?
This way?
Which way is west?
That's not west!
West!
Yeah!
Weest.
Not weest!
This is uncharted...
No, it's not.
Just kidding.
We've been here before.
Here, I'll get my stun rod out, even though I don't know how to use it.
Okay.
Easy now, Borgobi.
I'm trusting you.
Oh!
Oh, Borgobi!
Borgobi, we're in trouble.
I think I got him.
I think he spotted me.
No, you didn't.
Help!
Protect me!
I have no weapon except the law!
Oh my god!
Where is he?
Oh gosh, there's so many of them.
I could take them all out in one hit, Borgobi.
Okay.
Here, I'm gonna go get the other guy.
I'll CQC him.
I'll go CQC a guy.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to punch you.
So silly.
Where?
Tell him.
Ask him where the goods are.
That guy has good eyesight.
We'll take him home.
Wasn't there one more?
Oh, you.
This is what we C4.
Borgobi, watch out.
Watch out.
RT.
Wait, did I do it?
Is that mine or yours?
You're not gonna blow me up, are you?
Is this me?
This isn't mine, is it?
Why is my RT not working?
I'm so confused, you guys.
I'm actually...
I need
to aim it?
Okay.
That's why.
Oh my gosh, I'm so stupid.
Me too.
Oh.
Just a little surprise for the edit.
Yeah, as a treat.
Yeah, exactly.
You guys would be so proud.
Thanks, Borgobi.
Only a C.
He could have done better.
The next time I won't forget my gun.
I promise.
Super cute.
She wants to leave Sickbay and get back on the battlefield.
But she's not fully healed.
She's still in crutches.
Who'd be crazy enough to try and fight like that?
You have to talk some sense into her.
Okay.
Is she with you right now?
Why, Big Boss is the best.
She keeps shouting about how she doesn't want to be there.
She won't show up about it.
She's driving me...
Let her go.
What?
If that's what she wants, let her go.
I'm really not in the mood for jokes, Snake.
I'm serious.
Let her go.
Why?
So she can come back in a body bag?
I'm really not in the mood for jokes, Kaz.
Threw it right back in his face.
Amanda isn't the type to just sit around in Sickbay.
She has a sense of duty.
Her purpose in life is to fight.
The battlefield isn't just the best thing for her.
It's the best thing for her compas too.
She'll be a huge morale boost.
That can only benefit MSF.
You think so?
You're good at fighting, Kaz.
One of the best.
But you've got a lot to learn when it comes to people.
Says Snake!
I'll think it over and find a team for her.
Don't worry.
She won't let us down.
Mr. Charisma over here.
You have to learn about people.
Okay.
Kaz is like the most charismatic guy ever.
Yay!
We got the sniper rifle.
Rhinoceros.
Mandrill.
I'm just... oh.
I said I was gonna skip these but...
A new plant.
Yeah baby!
We're killing it.
Alright, let's separate our guys.
Adding... wait.
To the team!
Red Seabream!
Cleone.
Civet Cat.
Oh, he's a weapons technician, eh?
No, you're going into combat, mister.
Look how strong your combat is.
Amanda.
What is she going to?
What's the last one again?
Is that intel, I think?
Orko!
Even in game, I am haunted by Orko.
Kudu.
Snipio.
My cooking is 100% safe for human consumption.
Why would you say that?
Scorpionfish.
Red Seabream.
Sea Lemon?
What the heck is a Sea Lemon?
Armadillo.
Moss.
Okay, that's everybody.
And...
Auto assign.
Very nice.
Very good.
It's like a sea grape.
They're extra salty.
Lemons aren't salty, they're just sour.
Right?
Hello, hello!
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome in!
Let's see, what do we got?
What do we got that we can make?
This...
And this is currently...
Oh yeah, yeah.
This is the...
Wait, when did I start making this?
Solid Magazine.
When did I start making that?
Items...
Oh, we can make curry!
Oh, I thought we were making the analyzer.
Oh wait, no, this is a 2-star analyzer.
Let's make some curry.
What is this?
Surround indicator.
We have a good amount of GMP.
Let's do that analyzer.
Level 19 or higher.
We have current 20.
Nice.
Let's...
Oh, I guess we can do both.
Research the Doritos.
When?
When do we get the Doritos?
Okay, we got a top...
Oh wait, Amanda is free.
She's out.
Why doesn't...
Why doesn't anybody send me anything?
I got so much stuff on the PlayStation.
Why?
Did you sort the recruits?
I did.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
Metal Gear Grind.
I always am.
You sent me stuff?
Why?
Where did it go?
Why did Microsoft eat it?
They ate the curry.
Had I known this, I would have never played on the Xbox.
No.
Infiltrate the crater base.
Follow the nukes and infiltrate the enemy's main base inside of the crater of Irazu.
Towards the heart of the mountain.
That's its final destination.
We've got no intel on what lies beyond, so stay sharp.
Come on in!
Somebody.
And while you do that...
See, I saw this.
And I thought it was my...
I thought it was my...
I thought it was that.
But...
That should be good though.
What we have now.
What I have here is fine.
Welcome Requiem.
Any briefing files?
Let's talk to Miller.
Commandos.
No, I have clothes on.
Well trained and highly dangerous.
Amanda's crew calls them commandos.
Unlike the patrolmen, these guys will actively, relentlessly track and hunt you down like hounds.
Hmm.
Hounds to hunt a former foxhound.
Bring it on.
They won't give up easily, even if they lose sight of you.
They'll clear out any likely hiding places they come across.
So don't get too comfy in one spot, or you might get caught again.
Keep your eyes fixed on them and what they're doing.
Also, be aware that commando gear includes body armor.
So don't think you can deal with them by going in guns blazing.
I can deal.
All I've got to do is find an exposed weak point and...
Their crotch.
Wow, look at the thighs on those guys.
Wow, they really do.
What's Pies gotta say?
Where are we going to?
The canyon.
Let's see what she says.
Snake, to the north of the village is a bridge that crosses a hydraulic pipe.
Though normally the bridge is not used by people.
If you slip, you will fall straight to the bottom of the valley.
Be careful.
What's a channel doing here?
It is not for irrigation.
They are hydroelectric pipes.
I wonder if they run into Irasu's crater lake.
Normally they would build a reservoir at the bottom of the valley.
But it was probably too dangerous.
Los Cantos means Sword Peak.
It does?
Ready?
You ready Freddy?
He even unreadied while I was briefing.
Alright.
Let's go.
Start the mission.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for real now.
I'm ready to play the game.
Honestly.
Yeah, is Paz bluffing?
Is she telling lies?
She would never.
My precious Paz would never tell lies.
Take that back.
Nobody said it, but take it back.
Here we are.
We are the team.
Okay.
Do you think I can get this guy?
Hold on, I got this guy.
From here, I'm a sniping queen.
I got him.
I got him!
You don't have faith in me Requiem?
Jeez.
What are you... Why?
Why?
You don't have no faith in me.
You have no faith in me.
Do your little dance.
I don't want to... Oh shoot.
When did they start getting helmets?
Hold on, you take down one guy, I take down the other guy.
Oh, I was gonna...
Yeah, you get...
Oh...
Why?
You were supposed to take out the guy!
Requiem!
Requiem, we are in trouble now.
Oh you got him.
Nice.
What is it?
Nothing.
This is literally what Kaiz was warning us about.
They spotted you, they didn't spot me.
Is there anymore?
No, there is no more.
Easiness.
Easy peasy.
Requiem, what were you doing?
You fool!
Hey, come here.
What were you doing?
What were you thinking, soldier?
Apologize.
Sneak in.
Sneak out.
It's still stealthy.
Yeah, it's still stealthy if no one is left.
It's all good.
Oh, I remember.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there is... I remember.
There is a bunch of... There is a bunch of people in this area.
I remember.
I can't jump up there.
I'm too small.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can box.
Where is my box?
I forgot that you can do this, right?
How do you drop it?
A, right?
Yeah, see?
Who is here?
Who is up here?
Well, this is a good vantage point, no?
I can get this guy.
What?
Sentry!
Oh, shoot.
Why did I have to reload?
We are not doing so hot with this, are we?
Requiem, what happened?
We were the dream team.
What happened, buddy?
What happened?
We were the dream team.
Where are the rocket launchers at?
OK, I got that guy at least.
Oh, shoot.
I think we are OK.
No?
I got that guy.
He is gonna go down, no?
Oh, there is a guy down here.
Oh my gosh.
Where did you come from?
Do I have auto-aim on?
No.
Oh, he is a wimpy baby!
He is a wimpy baby!
Thank you!
Thank you, Fulton.
How many more guys are we taking?
How many more guys are we bringing?
Requiem, are you OK?
Are you alive?
I almost killed you.
I almost just did you a one-two.
Oh, he is out of bounds.
Hold on, I want to loot a little bit more.
It looked like it hurt.
No!
All my men are the strongest soldiers.
They would never get hurt so easily.
I thought there was a prisoner in this one.
Maybe I...
I thought that there was...
I think I was thinking of a different location.
That's OK, though.
That's my fault.
They start to look the same, huh?
You think we can get him?
Hold on, I'm gonna inch.
The next bit, I think.
Maybe.
Oh, my box!
I forgot my box.
Bye-bye!
You thought you heard a female voice by the box?
Yeah, right?
I thought so too.
Oh, we have another box?
Cool.
There's three guys up there.
I almost...
I almost pressed this to be able to mark them.
I'm just gonna shoot them.
Not headshot them.
Unless I'm really good.
OK, and just make them go...
Now they'll all fall asleep one by one.
Just a box.
We're lagging the game a little bit.
Thank you!
Alright, fall asleep.
Fall asleep, little baby.
Oh, there it is.
One down.
Oops!
There it is.
I timed it...
precisely.
You guys...
I knew what I was doing.
I knew what I was doing!
Oh wait, I should save some Fultons for...
I always forget that when I'm trying to...
run and...
I'm looting for...
for Mother Base.
I'm grabbing supplies.
Is that the hostage sound?
Oh my gosh!
Why didn't you take him down with CQC?
He was right there!
Who else?
I think there's somebody in here.
If I remember correctly.
There's definitely someone in this area.
I have four left.
You think I can...you think I'll be good?
When the VTuber backs you too?
Yeah, why not?
Hello?
You found him!
Good job.
I think there's another one though in the other area.
I think.
Is there anyone down here?
There's gotta be someone down here.
Doors are unusable.
Hello?
Is there someone in there?
There's nobody!
But I remembered that there was somebody in this map.
You good?
We're going inside!
I hope we don't get attacked or anything!
Shoot!
Shoot with the tank!
I like it.
Yeah, it takes two people.
It's such a big door, it should have two people.
Oh boy!
Oh golly!
No!
It's...
I don't remember the license plate.
Shucks.
I want to...
I didn't mean to do that.
Sorry.
I didn't press anything.
I just zoomed in.
Okay.
Definitely not that one.
It was not this one.
It had like a...
It's checking for me.
I want to make sure we don't accidentally do it.
Oh, it's that one, right?
Mr. Kojima!
Jackpot!
We got him, Mr. Kojima!
Mr. Kojima, it's not...
My leg!
These are such...
It's not this one either, no?
It's definitely this one.
Right?
Okay.
This one.
It's empty!
Just a box.
Mr. Kojima!
Oh no!
Okay.
No spoilers on Yui, you guys.
No spoilers on him, okay?
There's some people in chat that haven't played the game yet.
Do it.
Jackpot!
He's a thief!
The toast?
Like a toast.
I thought like bread.
Peace Walker!
I can't hear!
I'm kidding!
I'm getting so many flashbacks from this man.
Oh gosh!
Come to us, Stark.
We are going to have to meet it halfway.
For victory!
Cold Man!
Mito is here too.
Nuke!
Very slowly.
Making his way.
That's not good.
Animated comics are goaded.
They are so good, right?
Gosh, the art style is so awesome.
Hmm...
Couldn't hot cold mean lukewarm?
Yeah, but lukewarm man doesn't sound as fun, no?
Hatsune Miku!
Requiem, are you OK?
Oh gosh, Huey jumpscare.
In the next episode.
I can't remember.
I'm so bad.
I can't remember which one is which.
Like I know there is Pupa and then Chrysalis.
And then there is one more.
I can't remember what the last one is.
Chrysalis is the second one.
BabyCorn, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you so much!
Cocoon!
Was I thinking of cocoon instead of...wait.
That's what...yeah.
Pupa is basically Shagohan.
Oh, we had three alert phases.
None of them were me.
I'm just saying.
I've been awarded the butterfly title given to soldiers who mainly use short range weapons in favor of taking down enemies with non-lethal force.
That's me.
Huey!
Personally, I did not like that comic at all.
It doesn't do the main character justice.
I know.
Aw.
What's so sad is there's gonna be people being like, oh man.
Like I saw someone in the chat being like, I'm gonna find out why you guys don't like Huey so much.
Well, that actually...not in this game, but you will know!
Actually, in this game, he's pretty alright.
He's not so bad.
He's...well...
Hello Hideo Kojima.
Welcome to Mother Base.
Yeah, we'll get there in all due time.
In all due time.
Ooh, spicy curry.
Jaguar?
Bear?
Bull shark!
Why do you have wounds?
Was it me?
Uh-oh.
Sickness.
Octopus has hostility.
Alright, let's sort our guys.
Let's see who we've...
Oh wait.
Who we meet.
Seattle.
Hideo.
70% of my existence is made of movies.
It's...
It is up to you to decide what to do with the remaining 30%.
Starfish?
Timing is everything in consecutive CQC, you know.
Gotta be cool.
Press the button at just the right time.
What do you think this is?
Starfish a game?
Aardvark.
Govi!
You look prettier every time I see you.
He
thinks...
I mean, boss does have some really nice eyelashes.
Aguri.
Shuni.
Sunny.
Onager.
Agama.
What are these animals?
I've never heard of these before.
Otter.
Oh my god, Otter is setting up death flags for himself.
Drinks later?
It's on me.
Dies in battle.
Do they have any female soldiers in this?
I don't think so.
Another mission, right boss?
Oh, it's the... yeah, oh.
I was thinking...
I couldn't remember if they were in this one or B.
Only from POWs.
There you go.
Thank you.
See, chat is so knowledgeable.
I am not.
Badger.
Lion.
Skink.
Lemur!
Lemur, you've never been in a real fight before?
That's OK, we're putting you in the kitchen.
Bluegill.
Whoa, sea otter is goaded.
Oh my gosh, look at him.
Whoa!
The guy has crazy stats.
I just noticed.
Yeah, let's go.
High ranking.
Lime soda.
Lime!
Let's see.
We'll do another smoke grenade.
Even though I haven't used mine yet, but...
I like to carry them on hand.
Lime soda.
Oh, ration too.
Big.
What's this?
Oh, this is the surround.
Yeah, that's right.
Alright, next mission.
Who wants to fight Pewpa?
Who wants to fight Pewpa together?
I think lime soda was Mountain Dew.
I'm feeling more and more regret for not playing the PSP version.
Or the PlayStation version.
How is it that they didn't get Mountain Dew for the Xbox version?
How is it that they didn't get Mountain Dew for the Xbox version when the Xbox is literally lime green?
Wait, is that all that Mountain Dew is?
Is a lime soda?
The controls might make you not miss the PSP version.
Well, I mean, I'd still be playing it on the PS3.
It's dew from the mountains.
The licenses weren't in the HD collection.
Oh, really?
But I feel like I remember seeing it.
I think I'm gaslighting myself.
I have like gaslit myself into remembering these things.
Probably because I've also seen videos of it of other people having played this game and everything too.
Green soda.
Just tastes like Mountain Dew?
I don't know what that tastes like.
You're like the same people that are like, oh, it just tastes like Coca-Cola.
Okay.
Get on in here.
Alright, team!
Make sure you bring your big guns.
I don't think we need the smoke grenade, but I have already.
I have the supply.
Supply...
Maybe a C4, but oh, I have that too.
Do we want the assault rifle?
I don't think a sniper rifle will be worth it.
I just realized I got the sleepy sniper.
Nice.
Drink Mountain Dew?
I can't!
I can't have soda!
It doesn't mix well with the Ecuador Plaza.
And my swimming trunks, yeah.
Maybe I don't, but I kinda want the sniper so that I can have a precision on the pod.
Which would be better?
The M16 or the M60?
Hello, gun otaku, it's your time to shine.
Sodas are bad for you anyway, true.
M60?
Lucky!
Down with the tea!
Everybody ready with the tea?
I know it's so weird, I never recognized you guys' names, but it's really funny when I see you guys have usernames that's the same as your YouTube names.
And then I'm like, wow, you've been consistent for so long.
They make Mountain Dew flavored lip balm.
No idea how close it is, but there's a lot of soda flavored, non-soda things out there.
Yeah, I just never think about it until someone reminds me, you know?
I never changed mine.
I know, I remember seeing it.
I made my gamer tag in middle school and never changed it.
I get that though.
It's fun having a consistent name, like, online name for so long.
Then, you know, there's some people that I can't refer to them as, like, their actual name.
Like, I am like, you are your handle.
Look at his eyelashes!
He's so beautiful!
Hey, team!
We're the team!
Oh gosh, I have to remember how to do this fight.
I did it.
Let's go team, let's go!
Using the same username for most things for over a decade now.
Pupa!
I know, it's so fast!
Oh my god.
No shock units!
Ouch!
Oh!
Thanks, thanks Yui!
We're gonna kill this thing like crazy.
Bye!
Good job team!
I'm going!
She's already dead.
Damn, we didn't even, like, make it to...
That was so fast.
AI pod.
Space oddity time.
I love this part though, but it also makes me so sad.
I'm gonna turn it up.
I like this part.
Oh.
Ah, I missed!
I can't get that one.
I think it's getting too damaged.
Hey, does anybody...
Anyone wanna...
Anyone wanna damage that part so I can grab it?
This part... What is the C?
Looks like pudding.
I have 20 seconds and then there is an S.
I got the C!
Good job guys.
Good job, good job.
Oh, am I gonna have time?
No!
Ah, I missed one!
I shouldn't have dilly-dallied while waiting for the things to...
It's okay though.
We got most of it.
What do you get from doing that?
You'll see.
Mission complete, baby.
Goodbye, pupa.
Baby Shagohan.
It was so fast.
Gosh, they improved it so much.
She's going home.
Hatsune Miku, see you later.
Sorry though.
He's like shaking on the stairs.
Name's Hughie!
Right.
With a rocket launcher.
Oh, are you an entomologist too?
He's like fact-checking him.
He's fact-checking him on the spot.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Final phase.
Oh gosh, the ominous glow of his glasses.
Hey guys, no.
Stop!
I want people to...
I want to show them the cutscene!
Stop it!
The one you just fought was a pupa.
There's also a flying type called chrysalis and a treaded type, the cocoon.
Motor control, target detection, tracking, attack, capture and transport functions are all controlled by an electronic brain.
There's no need for a human pilot.
They can only follow simple commands though.
Why build them here?
What am I looking at?
Hot Cold Man.
Peace Walker.
Uh oh.
Where have you...
The butterflies.
Why do they make Yui so terrifying in these photos?
The terrain is full of tropical rainforest.
A lot of the time you can't even build a proper road.
So I went back to where it all started.
What's that?
Legs.
Walking power.
A mobile launcher carrying a thermonuclear warhead even more powerful than the Soviet RDS-220s.
That's Peace Walker.
Chico's Basilisco.
Basilisco.
We did the assembly and field testing here.
A walking nuke.
I sort of borrowed the original idea from Behind the Iron Curtain.
The missing link between infantry and artillery.
Metal Gear.
He's like, I like the sound of that.
They'd actually need to deploy dozens of them.
That's pretty metal.
Oh.
Which makes launching an act of suicide.
In the end, neither side can use its nukes.
It's thanks to this doctrine that the world's two superpowers have avoided all-out confrontation.
Nuclear deterrence has brought us peace.
At the very least, it's prevented another world war from breaking out.
But the theory of nuclear deterrence exists only on paper.
In reality, there's no guarantee that either side would follow through with retaliation.
Oh.
There's the chance that a preemptive strike could destroy all the missile bases.
Render them unable to retaliate.
But the biggest flaw in the theory is that the decision to retaliate has to be made by human beings.
Humans.
Let me give you a real world example.
Let's say Country X launches first against Country Y.
Then they just keep going?
If the people in charge of Country Y are like you and me, they're not going to be able to retaliate, knowing that they're effectively ending all human life.
So then the weak link in nuclear deterrence theory is the uncertainty of retaliation.
Bingo.
And that creates a loophole Country X can exploit to launch the first strike.
Which is why we designed the system to be unmanned.
With Peace Walker, retaliation is certain.
It chooses the appropriate target and launches a retaliatory nuclear strike.
Every time.
Anger.
Anger the robot.
Without needing human input to make the call.
Launching a nuclear strike against Peace Walker is tantamount to pushing the launch button against yourself.
It closes the loophole in nuclear deterrence theory, rendering our friends in Country X completely unable to launch.
What Coldman is saying is that to achieve this goal, we need to demonstrate that retaliation will be carried out by a machine.
He will launch his nuke.
And then his version of deterrence will be complete.
He's so scary.
I believe in peace through nuclear deterrence.
Why?
My father worked on the Manhattan Project.
He put his whole life into that research.
And all it created was this illusion of peace called deterrence.
This cursed ass family.
And then I was born.
Unable to walk.
Otacon, why'd you start working on Metal Gear?
I had no choice but to face up to the nukes.
Huey, why'd you start working on Metal Gear?
Oh, my father.
If they do end up launching, it'll all have been for nothing.
Huey, they've got to be stopped.
Why'd you make the nukes?
My father.
To a base near the border.
The final test is five days from now.
Where's the base?
You're gonna stop them?
It's kind of a hike.
And besides, there's a surefire way to halt the project.
You see, Peace Walker isn't quite finished yet.
What do you mean?
It's missing one last critical structural component.
The AI.
It's brain.
The reptile pod, the electronic brain I was working on, can only follow commands like Go there.
Attack that.
It's helping us achieve peace!
But for nuclear deterrence to work, it must function in place of a human decision-maker.
It needs something to analyze the huge volumes of data coming in and select an appropriate target for retaliation.
Hence, it needs the high-level decision-making ability of a cerebrum.
The mechanical cerebrum.
The hardware configuration is modeled on the human brain similar to the pod I worked on, but its role is completely different.
Where's it being made?
A research lab to the north.
An AI expert named Dr. Strangelove is developing it.
Very hush-hush.
Dr. Strangelove.
Strangelove was recruited from the States too.
In the field of AI, there's no one better, that's for sure.
But man, what a basket case.
Says you!
Especially you.
She hates everyone.
I'll lend you my ID card.
It'll get you through security at the lab.
Oh, and one more thing.
What's this?
A letter of recommendation?
Yeah, it's...
It's from me to Dr. Strangelove.
Don't read it, okay?
Okay, I promise!
Tear that sucker open!
So what will you do now?
I... I'm done with science.
At this rate, I'm probably already halfway to hell anyway.
This man can't stop lying!
Why are you always lying?
Oh my god.
Stop fucking lying!
I'm probably better suited to something like that than this paradise.
Sorry, I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna avoid...
We are in this game, everybody.
Can't get ahead of ourselves, okay?
I'm just really passionate, and I know you guys are all too.
Cause that's what you are!
Sorry.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done, I'm done.
Kiwi is just a silly guy in this game, for real.
A country without an army!
Thank you guys!
We spedrun that.
Look at that, 13 minutes.
Speedrun through the boss battles.
For anyone curious...
Also, if I'm gonna do any missions on my own or anything like that...
There might be a few that I choose to do on my own, but for the most part...
I don't mind actually speedrunning this game because...
I'm really just kind of going through it so that we can...
Go through the story and experience everything.
Taking it slow!
That's true.
It's not that I want to speedrun the story, but...
Look at this guy's smile!
I'm done with science.
Oh my god!
You just said you were done with science!
This guy is ridiculous!
That didn't take long at all.
He's like, just this once.
We'll make your weapon and then I'll stop.
What's that?
Oh, OK.
More money!
Oh yeah!
Miller's got a lot to say.
Country?
Huey in the kitchen?
Don't read Huey's letter, he'll be upset.
No, I won't.
My men!
I'm attached to my men!
We might lose men.
Outer Ops 2!
Lime soda!
Strange Love's Lab.
Chaff Grenade.
Oh yeah, I saw someone throw a Chaff Grenade earlier.
Good job.
Night Vision Goggles!
Lobster.
Alpaca.
Wild Fish.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to skip all these guys.
No plan.
Great stream.
Thank you Froggy!
Thanks so much for the superchat.
Oh my gosh!
A maximum of 100 people can be recovered permission.
Are there that many people?
Holy moly!
Super...
Oh!
Wow!
Thank you!
I received a gift!
I think I'm good on the tutorial.
I think I remember how it works.
Let's organize our guys real quick.
Support strike mark up.
Oh, I'm on Fulton Recovery 3!
Should we dispatch some guys?
Let's see...
I'm going to send out a mech.
We could get rid of some of the worst.
Well, there's no...
We don't know if they are going to die.
Would you consider Dr. Strangelove watch along?
It's been a while since I watched it, so yeah.
We had to get gifts after experiencing Huey.
I wonder why some people have tried sending and they don't go through.
I'm attached to Jaguar.
We're going to send some guys out.
Maybe I don't remember how this works, but I'm just going to go for it.
No!
Lizard!
Oh no!
Wait, what have I done?
What have I done?
Lizard!
I'm going to send Jaguar to watch over Lizard.
I don't think I need to send all these guys.
There's only two of them, but that's OK.
Launch an attack!
They'll all make it home safe, I believe.
Where is the...someone said it earlier.
We're going to go read that letter now.
R&D under other.
You're the best!
Thank you.
I wonder what it could say.
I wonder what it is.
Was it something I said maybe?
If so, I apologize.
I can't read it so fast.
Hold on!
The text is so fast.
I thought it would go up the entire screen.
Was it something I said maybe?
If so, I apologize.
It's just there's something I want to tell you, so I decided to put it in a letter.
I mean, obviously this isn't the best time and all, but I was, you know, kind of curious about your research and stuff.
Speaking of which, how's the pod coming along?
I was wondering whether that program I wrote was working out or not.
You know, the one that links our two AIs together?
If it's not, I could always go over and fix it.
If that's OK, of course.
For my own peace of mind, really, you know, make sure the program's feeling alright.
Or I guess I really wouldn't say the program has feelings, so...
Oops.
I hit my controller on accident.
He's rapping.
Rap God.
Look, we can even see his signature at the bottom.
Zoom in.
Can you guys read it?
I could always go over and fix it.
If that's OK, of course.
For my own peace of mind, really, you know, make sure the program's feelings are alright.
I guess you wouldn't really say the program has feelings, would you?
Haha.
Sorry, I'm getting off track here.
So anyway, I've been meaning to tell you something for the longest time.
I've been thinking, back when we first met at NASA, those were fun times.
You know, living the dream, getting to work all the time with the science we loved.
Ever since then, I've always held you, your research, in the highest esteem.
No more than that.
I think you're a wonderful person.
Sorry, I don't even know what I'm trying to say here.
So when you disappeared from NASA all of a sudden, I was devastated.
That's when I finally dawned on me.
I need you.
For my research, you see.
I mean, no.
Well, yes.
And no.
It's hard to explain.
Anyway, when I saw you again in Costa Rica, I could hardly believe it.
I thought maybe it was divine intervention or something.
You know, like it was written somewhere that we were meant to be like this.
You and me, the two of us from now on, you know?
Just you and me, Morty.
Sorry, wrong series.
Anyway, I'm doing research.
The research, uh, meetings.
No, I'm rambling again.
Sorry.
We don't have much time left.
When Peace Walker is finished, that's it, right?
That's the end of the project, so what I'm trying to say is, Peace Walker is kind of like something we create together, you know?
And when it's finished, then we'll...
I know we're not done yet.
We need to finish it first, right?
Yeah, until we do, I just hope you won't disappear on me like you did last time.
Sorry for taking up your time.
I wish you the best of luck with your research, your dear friend, Huey.
Thank you for reading that.
You see, Huey made the letter scroll that fast because he really didn't want you to read it.
I know!
He's such a silly guy.
Hold on, I want to get rid of all this, too.
No, no.
Oh, there's so many things.
OK, I give up.
On to Strange Love.
On to...
the start of my favorite part of the game.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Do we?
No, we don't.
See?
And Warp now exists.
It's a multiverse.
Alright, who wants to join, baby?
Huey!
Come on in.
Come on in, come on in.
Oh, wow, that was so fast.
Wayfarers!
Do we need...
Oh, I should put my...
Are we in the jungle still?
Survival.
Do we need our key?
I'll equip it just in case, because I feel like I'll forget it later.
ID card.
There we go.
Thanks, now I have crippling depression and trust issues.
Sorry, Huey!
Sorry, I mixed it up with...
the mail.
Sorry!
Let's go!
Strange love.
I thought you said snake love.
Survival.
Take your time, take your time.
I forgot to change my guns.
Chapter 2!
That's me!
The Phantom Hero.
Chico...
He gave me an axe?
Oh, Paz is so cute.
Wow!
That's insane.
I have it!
Oh, the butterfly!
I remember the ID, but not...
I remember the ID, but not my weapons.
Parasites.
Oh my god, Paz looks so cool.
OK!
I'll be careful.
There goes our mule.
Snake, Strange Love's lab is a few miles to the north.
It won't be long before the AI is complete.
Don't let that happen.
OK!
Just a mule.
I'm thinking strange love, strange love.
I'm thinking...
No, what's this?
It's...
Oh my gosh, look how cool we look.
Wait there, wait there, wait there.
I have a secret.
I'm about to tell you something.
It's all up to you buddy.
I left all...I left all my weapons.
I left all...
No, stop, stop.
This is serious.
I left all my weapons at home.
It's all up to you.
You got to try and...
What do you mean by that?
Do you see any men?
I can get them with my hands.
Probably.
Where's the men?
I'll get them with my hands.
OK.
Oh, I see them right there.
I see them in the tree.
Right there.
How do I zoom in this thing?
Can I?
Maybe not.
Good job!
I at least brought my Fultons.
Hey!
Wayfarer!
What happened?
What are you doing to that guy?
I'm kicking the air.
Where did that guy come from?
No reinforcements necessary.
No reinforcements.
Wayfarer!
I said it was up to you.
What the heck were you thinking?
What the heck were you thinking buddy?
Oh my god.
They are on their way.
I don't think they noticed.
Are you going to get them or...
I am a tree.
Are they going to come over?
Oh, nice.
Oh wow, they are really dumb.
Ok, this is good.
See?
Wayfarer!
What were you thinking standing out in the open like that?
They are going to see us!
Wayfarer!
What were you thinking?
Were you some kind of reckless newbie?
What is this?
Soldier!
Get your act together.
Wayfarer!
Wayfarer, that's not even a real person.
Wayfarer, that's a standee.
That's literally... that's not even real.
Get it together.
They keep sending me idiots when I ask for signs.
Yeah, kill it.
I'm just...
Nice.
Don't hit me though.
Alright, come on.
Let's keep going.
Wait, is there something we missed?
That's how you go back?
No?
We got everything?
I think we got everything.
Let's go.
Tranquil as a forest...
But afar... within...
Oh, wait.
Did I just go by myself?
Once you find your center...
You are sure to win.
Oh, you were here the whole time.
That's not a real person.
Don't get fooled, Wayfarer.
That's a fake.
That's a phony.
I'm sure there's real guys around here though.
Use your hands.
I see a guy.
I forgot that you can't move when you lay down in this game.
I'm gonna go take him down.
Nope.
Nevermind.
I changed my mind.
I didn't see that guy.
Oh.
Oh, he got me!
Wait, I got him!
No, he got me!
I was like, nice, I got him.
Oh, we're not getting an A on this one.
Oh my gosh.
Wayfarer, don't die.
Oh
my gosh.
Bring me back.
Hey, thank you.
I should...I meant to put my rations on.
My bad.
We're okay though.
Wait.
Great find.
Are you okay?
You're like bleeding out, Wayfarer.
Are you alright?
We need to go the other way, no?
No, we can't go this way.
Yeah, I know.
I don't know.
Gosh, he's so nosy.
Snake!
Are you gonna be okay?
You're beeping a lot.
You wanna lay on the ground a little bit?
Here, I'll lay with you.
There you go.
Yeah.
Come on.
Lay dead.
So convenient that CPR can revive you from bullet wounds.
I know, right?
This is peaceful, huh?
We're just...we're just two fellas lying on the ground.
In the middle of the forest.
After just killing a bunch of guys.
I'm going to full health.
What's wrong with you?
Peace layer.
Walking?
No.
Peace walker?
Peace laying?
Yeah.
Get up, soldier.
Come on.
We need to go.
Peace kicker.
Peace day will never come.
Maybe.
I mean...
Oh my gosh.
This just reminded me.
I can't wait for that one spooky mission.
And the extra ops.
I'm excited for that one.
Butterfly!
Oh!
This is...Oh!
I should have known this area.
In the next episode.
Yeah, we have rocket launchers.
We're all good.
We had a two camaraderie.
I didn't do those kills.
Those were not me.
Don't put that on me.
Naked.
Going with the tea.
Thanks, Wayfarer.
Why is it always everybody else that gets us into alert phases?
What if I didn't?
This guy literally can't help himself.
He can't help himself.
Yeah.
True.
Single handedly.
Sorry to have everyone join them.
Go down without a fight.
So don't get too preoccupied with this stuff.
Don't worry.
I'm not about to risk my life for a bunch of scrap.
I would hope not.
One more thing.
Our new bipedal weapon needs a name.
Good point.
We can't keep calling it our bipedal weapon.
I had a talk with Miller and we came up with Metal Gear Zeke.
Metal Gear.
He really liked the name Metal Gear.
I can't believe this.
I wonder who suggested the Japanese aircraft name.
What the...
I wonder...
Who suggested the Japanese name part of it.
Metal Gear Zero.
Weeaboo.
Was it perhaps this guy right here?
Kazuhiro Weeaboo Miller.
Obsessed with Japan.
Actually it's been two hours since the stream and we got our first Japan mention.
That's kind of impressive.
He's losing his senses.
I'm going to skip all this.
Wait, did our combat guys come back?
Oh, they returned.
And?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Auto play.
Why are they going after Koifu?
Oh yeah, take him down.
Kill that turtle.
Wait, can we get him to come to our team?
Nope, he's dead.
Woah!
Overkill.
Good job team.
Cardboard box tank.
Nice.
Anyways.
Level up!
We got Cougar.
He's a foodie.
Wish Warbler.
Gerbil.
Silkworm.
Hyena.
I love to grill things.
My favorite food is stir-fried noodles.
Those grilled chicken skewers they got in Japan are pretty good too.
Lobster has literally nothing to say.
Wow, a man of mystery.
Japan mention.
Megamouth shark.
DD Megamouth do.
Bob White.
I love this.
I'm a well-known journalist.
I'm going to write your story.
Well, not if you die in the battlefield.
Kill a monster.
Aguri.
That's all our guys.
Sonic Eye.
What did we need money for?
I don't remember.
It was like to expand the base, right?
I guess we just need more money in general, huh?
We have zero anything for Zeke.
It's just an empty, empty room.
So sad.
Peace Walker Zeke.
That'll be us soon.
We did grab...
I guess not the ones that we need.
This thing always confuses me.
Even with the tutorial.
I don't think even last time I played I finished it.
I don't think so.
That's OK.
Let's do chaff.
This is the strike mark.
I'll hold off for now.
Night vision goggles.
We could get a shield.
I pray NGS volume 2 has Peace Walker so latecomers like me can play online.
I know, right?
I hope so.
But then, what?
Do I play it again?
Maybe I play it again members or something.
I never did 100% the AI parts myself.
Yeah, it's OK.
OK, I think.
Again, again.
What's this one?
Oh, this is the surround.
Maybe the sonic eye.
Maybe not.
I promise you won't get mad.
MGSV was my first ever MGS game because I saw edits of it with Duran Duran.
No way.
That must be pretty recent then.
Night vision goggles.
We don't need the...
Fulton!
More Fulton!
Alright, you guys ready to fight an... I was going to say an aeroplane.
You guys ready to fight a helicopter?
Helicopter.
That's a very timely meme still, right?
Things everybody still talks about, right?
Get in here, folks!
I'm looking for the best of the best of the best.
Everybody came in so fast.
Worldwide!
Let's go.
I guess I still need the law, huh?
I have the grenade.
Smoke grenade.
This should be OK actually.
Mark 22 for recruits.
I hate that you're right.
I'm going to bring it so the law will be for the helicopter.
And then this will be for the people and I'll just use my hands for the people.
Mark 22 and M60?
Really?
Maybe the law is kind of slow.
Replace grenade?
I can't replace it with a weapon.
Like you can only replace it with...
What's this?
Oh wait, actually let me update my...
Oh, the fault is already updated.
OK, OK, OK.
Smoke plus trink gun trust.
I'm going to try and use the smoke grenades because I do want to bring these guys home.
But I don't think I'll... If I smoke...
I mean I could use like a...
Oh wait, I don't have night vision.
Gosh, I keep... I'm sorry.
I'm in such Ground Zero's brain right now.
Bring curry for the crew.
The curry!
We'll bring curry for the crew.
Where is it?
We got some curry.
Wait, the tortilla chips!
That might be the Doritos.
No?
Nah, this is fine.
You guys ready?
Doritos!
Silver...
Kino...
Brooks...
And Steak007.
93373.
You were like 007 but also of all the other people that claim to be 007.
Did you try like double... Did you go up from 1 until you got to a number that wasn't taken?
So you were like 0071, 0072, 0073...
And then you had to land on, you know...
007...
9...
Milm.
Ma'am.
Not ma'am.
Man.
It's the opposite.
Alright guys, try to bring some fellas home, OK?
Try to bring some guys home so we can...
So we can have some more armies, OK?
OK.
Let's find the...
Ouch!
What is wrong with you?
Why did you do this?
Oh my gosh.
Can
I get some here?
Yeah, let's take some home!
Let's take some guys home!
Where is the helicopter?
I can't see in my own smoke.
Ouch!
I tried to leave.
Where is everybody?
Where is the helicopter?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
Nice.
Oh, me too?
Oh, I went the wrong way!
It's just really smoky up in here, OK guys?
Very good, very good.
Take them home!
Now what?
Yeah, they don't know where we are at.
They are stupid.
We do also have to take off the ID, so...
If you guys could like, you know, also attack it.
Oh shoot.
There you go.
Good job team.
Take them.
Oh no!
Rooks are you OK?
I saw that.
How could you miss?
OK, let's focus on you.
Good job team!
Go team go!
Where is everybody?
They are all gone?
Good job everybody!
Go team go!
How many troops are in here, right?
Kept you waiting, huh?
Wow, this thing is really honed in on you guys, huh?
I'm absolutely chilling over here.
Guys,
it's up to you!
Oh, that's not my smoke grenade.
Where are you guys?
I can't see anything.
Did we get him?
Good job team.
I don't think I did anything, but that's alright.
I could throw... Oh wait, supply!
RT
That's not what I asked for.
That's not what I expected.
OK, there we go, there we go.
We're fine.
We
need a cardboard box.
Come
on team!
It's just a single helicopter!
Good!
Solid Snake can do this in his sleep!
This thing is really beefy.
Dang, they don't make Hind D's like they used to, huh?
Hey Rook, you doing alright?
You doing OK?
Did you just drop some more chips?
Oh, thank you!
Rook, Rook, Rook, Rook!
Oh shit, I didn't think that was gonna hit me.
You got him?
That guy right there?
We can take him down.
We can take him.
You can also tranq the leader?
You can?
Where is he?
Wait!
Let's get the leader!
Let's tranq him!
Nevermind.
Wait, you got him.
How did you get him so fast?
Why did you do that?
Who did that?
What the heck?
High caliber tranq sniper.
Very good!
Good
job!
Damn!
Oh my gosh, our camaraderie was great!
Seventeen!
Seventeen people!
Sneaking suit!
Good job team!
What do you mean by that?
Yeah I don't...oh no
I think we can!
The power of Boss Mito and her culinary team at full display.
I need to find my eye drops.
Shock builds character.
They need to know what we are all about.
Delivery!
Really?
Lemon.
Tarpon.
Oh my gosh, every single one of those guys got sent to the brig.
No way!
Rooks!
Thank you!
Is that all you said?
What is it?
A magazine for inside the love box.
Go, go, go!
Is it all tortilla chips?
All tortilla chips!
Thank you very much.
I'm craving some Doritos now for real.
My monitor arm that was supposed to come today was delayed to tomorrow.
Can you use your Metal Gear Zeke to smite those responsible?
I will!
Gosh, that's the worst.
That's actually the worst when you are looking forward to something and you are like it's going to come today, it's going to come today...
And then it doesn't!
Awful.
For now...
For now I think we are okay.
Make the rocket launcher, you'll need it for Miku.
It's after this one.
Or the one after.
We have a little bit of time between next Miku.
Actually, oh wait, but I do want to... Then I need to develop it, because it needs time to develop.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need it.
I was thinking about it, I was like...
But it's not just a one and done baby.
Okay.
Oh, and our guys.
I forgot to... Oh, we only have two guys.
Spitter...
And grouper.
Spitter?
I hardly grouper.
Don't forget to change your weapon this time.
I know, I know!
I know!
Thanks for taking out that helicopter with me boss.
Yeah!
Getting to play my favorite franchise in multiplayer in 2025 was such a treat.
And playing with my other two?
What do you mean?
WSF forever!
My Oshi.
All good.
Walkman!
Wait, hold on though.
I was waiting for this.
We are so close.
No!
I don't have enough money.
Wait, can I go into debt?
I can!
I'm in debt, I'm in debt, I'm in debt, I'm in debt.
Yes.
We'll get more money, don't worry.
My Minto merch arrived today.
I'm Minto3, best day ever!
Munekin!
Thank you for getting it.
Let's recruit some guys too.
I'm sending out a notice.
Who would like to join Minto-san's Frontiers?
I'm putting out a search at this very moment.
Wait, I thought we weren't supposed to be...
I thought we weren't supposed to be so heavy handed.
I'm the real deal?
Upskirts.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Hello!
Oh you?
Good second.
Did I get him?
This guy is tough.
Still?
Go down!
I thought I was going to be running through the jungle.
Managing to capture a Hein with one of my two OG's Ember Wisps.
One of my favorite franchises.
Life is good.
Thanks Snake.
Thanks for joining.
That was a lot of fun.
Wow, they must have really liked me.
We gave up our homes, but we're still alive.
We're still fighting.
There, there.
You're always going to get interrupted.
Nice.
Nice and nice and nice.
I wonder how good they are.
Cabbage what?
Rattlesnake!
No, please no!
No!
I'm in trouble.
Nice.
We at least got one good guy.
I'm not in debt anymore.
Continue the development.
We're not in debt anymore.
Make my stuff.
OK.
I'm excited.
Who's joining me today?
We're going into the jungle.
Well, we've been in the jungle.
We're going into the ruins.
This is like a very special job, OK?
Whoever comes in, you've got to be special.
Maubius!
You're special.
OK, I'm going to change my stuff.
Oh wait.
Do I need to?
Oh wait, actually...
I am going to bring only non-lethal stuff.
I hope you don't mind.
And I got the card.
Let's go!
Reporting for duty!
Sneak suit?
I've got to develop that still.
No?
I've got to develop it, no?
Oh I obtained it.
I'll switch later.
Is it all the fatigues you don't have to develop?
Those are automatic?
I feel like the sneaking suit is special, no?
Wow.
Hello!
Alright Maubius, I don't have anything secret to tell you because I have everything...
Wait, is there anything in here?
They'll never hear me coming.
Never hear you coming!
Alright, alright.
Let's keep going.
It is this way, yeah?
Let's go baby!
Let's go baby.
Look, we could've avoided the helicopter, but...
I think Kazuhiro Miller is trying to sabotage us.
Alright.
Dirt?
Do you see any guys?
I'm looking with my special...
Will they hear this?
Clearly not.
I'm scared.
Thanks.
Wait, how are you so far ahead?
Wait!
Wait for me!
Are you taking them home?
I can do it.
They're coming home.
Where is the laser sight at?
Did I already get that guy?
Because I'm too good?
Oh, you got another guy down over there!
I see him.
You're so good.
You're fast.
Wow.
Alright, nice.
Nice speed running.
Alright.
We continue onward.
I wonder if they'll hear me again next time.
Do you see anyone?
I don't see anyone.
Oh you do?
Where is he?
Where is he at?
I don't see anyone.
Where?
Do you guys see anyone?
Wait.
I just heard a guy.
Maybe?
Where is he at?
This part makes me so nervous.
Where are they?
I'm gonna take this guy home.
No!
Hello!
He's so loud, right?
Oh, is he behind the wall?
Oh, he's in here maybe?
Oh my gosh.
The prisoner!
Is somebody there?
I'm gonna switch to not my, you know, my sniper if I don't need it.
Oh!
Oh my God!
I would have never seen him coming.
Damn!
Yeah, rob him of all his worth.
Oh, he's got Lime Soda!
You're coming home with me.
Dang, you know where all the guys are.
I love people when they play games a lot.
Oh, I see him too.
I'm just gonna take him out.
Look at him.
He's already asleep.
What are you, the end?
Impressive.
No, you showed me!
You showed me!
Is that it?
Let's keep going baby.
Going well.
Bird.
Oh my gosh, could it be a lovely lady?
Oh,
she's French.
French.
Cash, cash.
A cash, cash.
Cecile!
Ok guys, if I look it's not my fault.
She's just like that.
French.
Cash, cash.
The pretzel?
Yeah, the pretzel.
I'm also...
I am also an ornithologist.
The pretzel?
Yeah, we the pretzel.
Oh my god, we gave her Mountain Dew.
Oh, how is this American drink is...
So, it's disgusting.
As you would say, it's disgusting.
That's me saying this.
You can hear it.
And then you also hear Hatsune Miku's song.
That's right, remember?
Last time we heard the boss's voice.
But why?
Will you play the newest MGS?
Of course!
Out of her own kindness, obvious.
Obviously.
Out of the kindness of her heart, she bathes you.
How'd you escape?
I waited for an opening.
Stole an ID card.
They almost caught me, but I managed to elude them.
There's a pretzel right above you.
I was barefoot, with no supplies.
Mountain Dew.
I am so sorry.
I drank it all.
She's so cute.
That facility... did you see anybody else in there?
Well, there was another woman, but I never saw her in person.
Because, you know, the blindfold.
Oh yes!
She often sang.
Sang?
Hatsune Miku.
It was such a strange song.
What kind of person was she?
Could you tell anything from her voice?
I don't know.
I don't even know why I was held a prisoner.
They confiscated my equipment, my supplies, my passport, money... everything.
The only thing I was allowed to keep were my undergarments.
So that I would not be able to escape.
And now, I am without even the means to prove who I am.
I will not make it home to Paris like this.
No Paris!
Yeah, we can call everyone Lizard.
And Monkey.
Ok man, beggars can't be choosers.
Ok.
Wow, he's risen her up.
Did it hurt when you fell from Outer Heaven?
No.
There was a tube.
A large tube in the back.
When I approached it, I heard a voice.
What did it say?
Jack.
Yes, it simply said Jack over and over.
Jack?
Listen, you've got to get me out of here.
I really need a shower.
Wait here.
I still got business to take care of.
What?
You're not thinking of going in there, are you?
You can't leave me here.
I'll have some friends pick her up.
We have a...oh.
He's going to be very excited.
It's a woman!
It's a lady!
Lady!
Female!
Female.
Kazuhira Miller.
So she's safe then.
Good news.
I'm sure Paz will be glad to hear it.
You bet.
Snake, the ruins are just up ahead.
Head north.
On my way.
On my way!
What about me?
We acquired Cecile.
Yay!
Oh that's right.
Just a little bit more.
Wait.
I'm going to switch to my...
Can they hear this?
I don't think they can.
I think they're really silly.
Thank you!
Morbius!
Oh.
I see him right there.
I see him.
You got him.
Oh.
He's looking this way.
He's looking directly at you.
You got this.
Oh.
Get him in the butt.
Oh there's like a bunch of them.
I think they'll hear that.
What's wrong?
Get him out!
Nice!
We got this!
Don't even need to...
Oh.
I see him.
Wait.
I want to take you home.
No!
Dang it.
I couldn't line up my shot fast enough.
Why do you take what?
What do you mean?
Oh.
There's a guy over here.
I'll get him.
Uh oh.
This is my last one.
Wait.
Are there any... I think there's some prisoners around here.
No?
Or am I crazy?
Are there prisoners here?
Spin for yes!
Maybe?
Do you have...
No.
Do you have a fulton?
Oh no!
Oh man.
Oh no.
It's ok.
You didn't have to use that.
It's not that important.
I had one too.
Oh they didn't give me... Ok.
Hold on.
Let me try.
Land on me.
No!
They didn't give me any!
What?
Stingy!
It's probably because I ran out...
Stingy guys!
Um.
Sorry prisoner.
Sorry.
I knocked him out.
I couldn't...
Ok.
Let's just go.
My fault.
No, it's ok.
It'll take two people.
It'll take two... people.
No, drag them back to the pickup mechanic here.
Unfortunately, no.
V makes a lot of improvements.
Well, improvements and also...
They added the realism of the... What's it called?
So basically in this game you can fulton anybody indoors or outdoors.
But...
She blocked him!
Damn!
She hates him!
Yeah, in this game you can fulton anybody from anywhere but...
In V...
You have to drag them outside.
Until you get improved ones.
I still got a prisoner?
When did I get that?
Oh versus.
Until the wormhole.
lol
I was never exactly her favorite.
So...
In my bedroom.
I mean...
lol Oh my god, Cecile's Ace Combat era.
Relatable.
Yeah, how relatable.
Oh no.
We have to listen for the cat cell.
Wait, she just took a bird?
lol
She's such a trickster.
lol What's that?
You took a bird?
I thought it was under the tree.
Oh Snake.
He's such a silly goose.
Nice.
Strange.
Sus.
Orange jacket.
Alright.
Should I do this one on my own?
How do I want to do this?
Because I don't want to play with someone that knows where they are.
You know what I mean?
We take men all the time.
Can we really criticize her for taking birds?
Oh yes, Cecile.
Yay, all of our stuff.
Delivery!
Delivery.
Uh oh, Yellowtail, why are you sick?
What did you eat?
Cicada.
Robin.
Caribou.
Staff has not been assigned to a team.
Oh, did I not do that last time?
Doritos.
Oh Morbius, thank you!
Morbius.
Thank you for the full team!
Sleep gas mine.
Nice.
Wait, how does that work?
Solid.
Liquid.
Solidus!
Those are good, aren't they?
Everyone keeps sending them to me.
Land Iguana.
Oh my gosh, we got a Dodo!
Dodo.
Pilot Whale.
Thanks Mito for letting me help you to open the way.
Another day in the office for me.
You can count on me anytime.
Thank you!
Thanks for helping.
Skunk.
Komodo Dragon.
Boss, if you find me lying face down on the battlefield, you gotta revive me.
But no mouth to mouth, please.
I want Komodo Dragon off my base.
He is not a team player.
Alpaca.
Lemming.
Pronghorn.
Sailfish.
Skimmer.
Great Dane.
Wasp.
Waspinator.
Cormorant.
Cheetah.
Koipu.
Bobwhite.
Terrier.
Silago.
Tarpon.
Seseal.
Gosh, she is so beautiful, right guys?
How can he say no mouth to mouth from Snake?
That's what I'm saying.
Look how beautiful she is.
Wow!
Madam!
Thank you Kojima!
Kojima is god!
Ibex.
Black Seabream.
Kangaroo!
That's all of them.
Still no leech, you guys.
Assault Rifle.
Sniper Rifle.
Grenade Rink 2.
Chaff Grenade 2.
Support.
C4 2.
Glovebox 2.
Words and deeds.
I'm not regretting them.
Oh my goodness, we have so many things.
Holy moly!
Make.
What else do we have in here?
Our Walkman.
Glovebox.
What makes it better?
Bigger cardboard box.
Might fit two people.
Modified to improve durability.
Night vision.
Hmm...
We could do...
Baby car!
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Big box.
Night vision goggles and Walkman.
Get more Fulton stuff with the landmines.
What do you mean landmines?
I didn't have that.
Hmm...
I
don't know what I want to make.
I have all this money.
And too much indecision.
There is a Fulton landmine that comes up later.
I
think people have been giving it to me, right?
This one?
No, this is the gas mine.
Actually, how do you use this?
Oh, wait.
Sleeping automatically executes Fulton recovery on targets after they fall asleep.
How do you use this?
I prefer non-lethal probably.
You have to get them to patrol into it.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Chap is useful against boss fights.
That is true.
We'll at least do that.
I think we'll be good.
I'm going to hold off for now.
Until we have a more...
Maybe we'll get something else too.
That will be good and require a lot of GMP.
Alright.
Yes!
Orange jacket!
Orange and Kettle.
Body check.
Okay.
Alrighty.
This should be fine.
This should be... Wait, maybe...
Oh, it also switched to Fulton 3.
Yippee!
Combat.
Oh, Micmac.
Hello.
Should I stealth too?
Where is my stealth?
I love the beach.
Wait.
I want that one.
I don't have it yet.
I love the beach.
Oh, there it is.
Sneaking.
Stealth.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait.
I don't really need the love box, but whatever.
Oh, I don't need the ID card anymore.
Walkman.
Maybe the speak to sound thing?
If we are searching for a bird.
One moment, please.
I have to give all my stuff back.
You are out here stealing men again?
Yes, I am.
I am.
I love the beach.
Wait, did I attach the Fulton?
Oh, yes, I did.
My bad.
They are like, you are going to be snake whether you like it or not.
Let's just take some curry.
Wait, did I look in here?
Oh, that's all of the stuff.
Oh, I forgot my weapons.
You...
We can do the magazines.
We can distract them with a silly little magazine.
They will be like, yummy.
You know?
But we don't want to Fulton the guy...
That we are trying to take.
Oh wait, this is all placeable weapons.
I am silly.
Smoke.
I am just grabbing whatever.
Oh wait, where is my regular...
Where is the empty mag?
There we go.
We will do a bunch of distraction things.
Everything is distraction.
Thank you.
Oh, my bad.
Cecile, what does it sound like again?
She is staring into my soul.
That's all I am.
Wow.
Oh.
Oh,
room for the ID card.
Guys.
I was driving the other day.
And on the side of the road I saw a peacock.
I don't know why.
Sounds like there is a peacock.
I found the...
Okay.
How does it taste?
That one sucks Cecile.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
Let's take out the curry.
Wait, how do I remove it?
How does it taste?
Okay, you guys remember what the pretzel sounded like?
I wanted to hear her monkey impression.
I am not going to lie.
Starting the mission.
Kyoa!
It is in another tape?
Oh my gosh.
We gotta hear the monkey.
Hi snake.
Oh my god.
I love the beach.
Not that guy.
I'll get him.
That's not the right weapon.
We are fine.
Everything is good.
Can I take this guy home?
Hey, you are not going home!
Hey, get up!
What are you doing?
Get up!
You are not a cat either.
How do I get out of here?
This way?
Oh, there is a guy over there.
What?
What are you doing to me?
Yeah!
Oh, you got the banana even.
I want your stuff.
Give me your stuff.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Oh my gosh, I'm patting his butt.
Stop!
I can't get his stuff.
Don't do it!
Alright, let's take him home.
He is just a silly guy.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
Wait, what does it say?
Get your hand off of me!
This game is so fun.
I love Peace Walker.
Where are we?
Oh, I'm coming too.
You got him?
Oh, you already got this guy.
Stop messing with him.
Come on.
We don't need him.
Where are the other guys?
Where are they at?
Oh, there he is.
Hey, you just ran right past him.
I got him.
No,
he got me first.
No, he got me first.
What does that mean?
Oh, he got me again.
A little help.
A little help here.
Thanks,
I guess.
We are on the ground.
What
the?
What the heck just happened?
Nice!
We double teamed those guys.
I'm gonna take some of them home.
Yeah, we saved.
That guy teleported though.
You guys saw that, right?
We'll take the end home too.
Do you hear a kettle?
He cheated.
He's using hacks for real.
OK.
Isn't it in here?
Am I crazy?
Thank you!
Yeah!
Where the hell is this bird?
Do you hear him?
He's not here.
I think we gotta keep going south.
What are you doing to this guy?
Come on.
I'm not gonna take everybody.
We are an exclusive club now.
Click, click, click.
That's all I remember.
Is there even anybody here?
Oh there is.
Oh!
No.
Freeze.
OK.
I hear the kettle.
Do you hear it?
There it is!
Excuse me.
Can you move?
Can you get off this guy?
Go away from him.
I don't want to see your crotch.
Oh my God.
OK guys.
Can I take him home?
Yeah!
Thanks underwear man.
He's got his banana out.
Don't say it like that.
Alright, back to the lab.
Back to the lab everybody.
Oh the traps.
Oh shoot.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Yeah, I want to test using them, right?
The, uh...
Automatically executes Fulton recovery on targets after they fall asleep.
How do I use this?
Well this guy...
Is there a guy over here still?
I guess I need to walk into it, huh?
Oh he's still asleep.
Alright,
drag him over it.
Oh my God, moss man.
This was such a bust.
He's all the way over there!
Just asleep.
Come on!
Wake up snake!
Can you wake me up?
Thank you.
Where's
the reinforcements?
Nice.
I don't think the reinforcements ever came.
You had this the whole time!
Don't be so dramatic.
Don't be so dramatic!
This guy is all slumped over.
Maybe if I...let's see.
If I put it like right...there.
Oh me too.
It's really potent.
Wake me up!
Thank you.
Alright, let's go.
The reinforcements did come.
Stupid.
They really did show up.
Micmac is just too good.
I didn't even notice they were there.
I can see you!
These guys are no good.
I'm getting bad vibes.
No, nevermind.
I changed my mind.
One of them might be Leech.
That's where the bad vibes come from.
You missed!
Computer, I need the second person!
Betrayal.
I know!
Micmac how could you betray me?
How dare!
Alright.
I like when it's co-op.
I can see your radar.
Wait, let me see.
Yeah, see?
When it's co-op.
Chat is kind of blocking it, but when it's co-op...
No!
You're lagging!
You're cheating!
We're in sync!
We're so in sync!
Alright, story time.
I should have gotten some water first, but that's OK.
Oh, because of Snake Inn?
Because we were in the co-op?
That's so funny still.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts!
That was fun.
That was so silly.
Oh.
It can't be.
Oh my god!
What?
That guy always keeps you waiting.
Don't move!
No!
It's trauma.
He never did!
No!
Is that what you call the truth?
Totally gaslit himself.
You were there, Snake!
You were the woman you loved most in this world before you buried her.
It was my mission.
So that's the conclusion you came to in order to live with yourself.
What's the boss to you?
I'm the one she abandoned when she left this world.
I won't rest until I get answers from the woman I loved.
You and I are the same.
We are the walking dead.
Uh-oh, AMC's gonna be suing.
The boss is gone.
Not so fast.
You'd like to meet her, wouldn't you?
I can arrange it.
You took her life.
I gave it back.
You what?
Care for a sniff?
It's only snuff.
You're a cigar man, aren't you?
Well, there's no smoking in there, so if you want to meet her, you'd best partake now.
Follow me.
This is my baby.
My morpho butterfly.
It's neither pupa nor cocoon, but an amalga.
A complete individual in the fullest sense of the word.
Is someone there?
We have a visitor.
I'll introduce him.
Don't try anything foolish.
As long as we're in here...
I'm gonna cry!
...I can introduce you with calm and the press of a button.
Who are you?
A warfighter.
Boss?
Is that you?
I call it the mammal part.
Mammal part?
For my participation on the project, I demanded access to all information on the boss.
Everything the CIA had.
Her personal history, military records, physiological data, correspondence.
The files for every operation she took part in.
Every decision she ever made at every possible turn.
What she took and what was taken from her.
Her pain and her pleasure.
Her joy and sorrow.
Her life and death.
And yes, even you.
Why would you do that?
Coldman sought an MAD-based AI that would deliver an effective retaliatory strike against the most appropriate target in response to a nuclear attack from a hypothetical adversary.
An unmanned device to act as a deterrent capable of making the decisions and taking the actions that human beings cannot.
I therefore concluded he required a cool calculating machine, programmed to inflict swift, sure, and utter annihilation upon the enemy.
No retaliation.
But he took it upon himself to come up with a different answer.
He said he needed the thought patterns of the very finest rational mind.
One that thought on a global scale, took both past and future into consideration, and reached the best...
What is that O?
It's different.
It's two different O's.
It was the logical thing to do.
I knew of only one person who could be entrusted with the fate of the entire human race.
No pressure for her.
To clear her name.
Why was a legendary hero forced to betray her country?
Why was she targeted for assassination by you, her most beloved disciple?
I have no use for fabrications.
I want the truth.
The boss's last will.
You must be dying to know yourself.
No.
She abandoned her country.
Abandoned us all.
Really?
You think you understand her feelings?
You're trying to recreate the boss's last will.
Is that it?
Why don't you ask her yourself, Jack?
Jack!
What?
Boss!
Jack!
Go home.
I'm not your boss anymore.
Boss!
Go home!
No, I...
Complete your mission, Snake.
Extinguish that noble soul once again.
If you can.
Oh my gosh, we're trapped in the mammal pod.
My heart.
It's so weh.
Loyalty to the mission or loyalty to me?
Jack!
I'm
not your boss anymore.
Go home.
Why did you come back?
I'm not your boss anymore.
Go home.
You better stay around from now on.
Cal 9000.
I'm not your boss anymore.
Go home.
Yoink!
I'm not your boss anymore.
Go home.
What is this?
This response?
Oh god.
Discontinue!
Whoopsie.
I taught you all I could.
The rest you needed to learn on your own.
Techniques, sure.
But what about how to think like a soldier?
Oops.
There's a saying in the Orient.
Loyalty to the enemy.
Do you know what it means?
Being patriotic.
It means devoting yourself to your country.
Oops.
The BGM kills me.
I didn't get the RT.
Oops.
What the?
What?
I get...
Why is it saying beep beep?
I did break trigger.
What are you talking about?
With absolute certainty is the mission.
I'm defecting to the Soviet Union.
Jack, you can't come with us.
You can't sit with us.
Boss!
Go home, Jack.
He's like, what happened in there?
The flowers.
Oh
my god!
What are you doing back there?
What?
That looks familiar.
Mercenaries!
To be continued in the next...
Hatsune Miku time baby!
Let's go.
I wonder how long I'll go today.
We'll definitely beat Chrysalis.
Going all in.
Thanks boss.
Thanks Eggman!
That was so fun!
Speedo guy whiplash.
So funny.
Yay!
Sub-arrival.
Skip.
Shrimp!
What are you doing in there?
Salmon.
I'm Solid Snipe.
Sony.
Capybara.
There's no reason a capybara should be in the brig.
You chose the wrong name for yourself.
We got Dorado!
Cicada.
Robin.
Crane.
We got the goat!
Goat!
We got goat!
Kestrel.
Goanna.
Caribou.
Reindeer.
Oh my god!
Sea otter!
We got the goat!
That's it.
Gosh, are we never going to see Leech again?
I guess we'll see.
Look at our base.
You guys, it's really starting to shape up.
Let me out!
You gotta be a good boy, everybody.
Oh wait, sorry.
This one.
You gotta be only good boys and girls.
We could get D+.
Should we send our same guys?
It should be, maybe...
No, I'm sending out a mech.
We're sending this bad boy out.
What if I also send out our helicopter?
Oh, we have a tank too!
I didn't even notice.
We're sending out all the big boys.
Oh, I'm so silly.
Sending out all of them.
Let's take them all.
Launch and attack!
Send Orca.
Let's see.
Anything else we can recruit?
Anymore guys?
Hi Cecile.
You people are such culinary savages.
Why does she think that about us?
What's that about us?
Entrance exam.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
Let's go, let's go.
Yeah, we have curry.
We have deliciousness.
We have Doritos and curry and Mountain Dew on Mother Base.
That's a lot of guys.
Hello?
There we go.
Yeah, you just got up and I'm taking you back down again.
Oh no!
Please!
So close.
Consecutive.
I also call out every move that I do.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
You're pretty good.
Strange love!
Her quote is so messed up.
We have a winner.
Well, not really, but...
Let's go see who we got.
Bobolink?
What's with these angry guys?
Arowana.
Swallow.
Falcon.
He's not very good.
The other guys are good.
Do you see what I see?
Oh my god!
We have a...
Sound the alarms!
We have a female!
We have a lady.
Give me any order you want and I'll make it happen.
Alright, J.
I command you to stay with me for the rest of my afterlife.
Crane!
We got some pretty decent guys this time.
Nice.
They really gave her that quote.
Yeah, they did.
Alright, Chaff is still in the works.
We're about to face...
Oh my gosh!
J!
We're about to face Chrysalis.
I think we're okay with what we got.
Chrysler.
Alright, I need four strong guys to come help me out.
If you play as J...
I know what to do.
Come on in.
Nice!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Let's see.
Mission prep everybody.
Get your stuff ready.
Hold on, wait.
Yeah, it should be fine.
Solid magazine, no.
We'll go with the grenade.
We don't need this either.
We'll go with... I already have this.
I guess we don't.
I don't really need anything.
We need that.
I'll bring that.
Don't need that.
I'm gonna bring another curry though, just in case.
That's the surround indicator.
I didn't even use my Walkman.
Oh Chaff, thank you!
Thank you for the reminder.
Oh wait.
There it is, yeah.
Gone with the team.
Oh, sorry.
I have to redo all my stuff.
Sorry, sorry.
So sorry.
I have to redo all my stuff.
Huey's ID card.
Blah, blah, blah.
I want to take a picture of all of us.
I've been meaning to do that and I keep forgetting.
I don't really need the analyzer, do I?
What's this do again?
Oh, yeah.
Thank you!
Are we ready, team?
Team!
We'll be fine.
We don't need another curry.
Alright guys, before you do anything, let me take a picture.
I want to take a picture of us.
Our little team.
You missed the panties.
I don't have that yet, but I'll get that.
I'll get that outfit.
Bye bye!
This time...
This time I stream this game we are getting our date with Kazuhira Miller.
I swear on it.
We are getting that date.
Roger that, boss.
Cross your heart and hope to re-die?
Yep.
Cross my heart and hope to live.
Alright guys.
Cheese!
Where are you going?
Come here.
I can't get all of you guys.
Don't worry about it.
Cheese!
Mash it!
I
wish I could...There we go.
No, the battle pod!
Take that!
Nothing.
Come back please.
I have no more!
Are you not an attack pod?
Is it too far?
It's too far!
I should have not brought the gun.
I should have brought...
Sorry, I'm taking your stuff.
I don't know if that's for me.
Launching kidnappers.
Abuse!
Don't be kidnappers!
I'm an adult!
There we go.
Nice.
Good job team!
Where is she?
There she is.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Team?
Are we okay team?
No more kidnappers!
Oh, I thought I got the pod before,
but...
The pod!
No, no, no, no, no!
No chain gun!
Morpheus!
Oh, you're fine.
You're just getting health, right?
I'll also join you.
You scared me!
I thought you were down!
Wait, we lost someone.
Wait, did someone disconnect?
Wait, Morpheus, why don't...
What just happened?
Not yet!
It's not over yet!
I was an idiot.
Why did I...
Why did I not bring both...
Both things.
Why did I bring one gun?
Oh my god.
The chaff grenades, thank you!
The chaff grenades are so good!
Nice!
It's alright, the chaffs!
What do you mean?
No!
I tried to do it before she could do it.
I tried.
Wait, I have no more again.
Yes, please!
Oh, more rations!
Awesome!
Oops, I guess I died.
She's gonna land on the supplies!
Ouch!
Wait, stop, thank you!
Oops, I guess I died.
Hello team!
Thank you very much!
One guy is glitching out a little bit.
I win it!
Too close for a bazooka?
Never!
What are you talking about?
Holy cow!
Holy moly!
Come on Snake!
Snake, I need you to really stuff those in there!
Yes, I need you to stuff them in your pants!
I need you to...
Oh my god!
OK!
Stuff it in there!
Make sure it's...what the?
What just happened?
Are we good?
Are we OK?
This one.
What just happened?
This one?
Come on Snake!
Grab it!
I couldn't get it.
No!
It's OK though.
I got like almost half of them, so that's not so bad.
Good haul though, yeah!
Cold man jumpscare!
This thing!
This stinking AI bot!
Oh my goodness!
Oops, I guess I died.
Hi team!
By the way, all three of you!
So funny!
I've been the main character every time!
Good job everyone!
Carl Gustav M2 Design Specs, rank 2.
Support strike?
Not quite!
We got this!
Yeah!
Thanks for the reminder!
Strange love is piano and Huey is a fiddle!
Kaz!
That machine's not the problem.
It's that the boss still lives inside of you.
Bullshit!
She's dead, Snake.
It's time to come to terms with that.
Let me put it another way.
You've left everything behind.
Your country, your identity, your past and ideals.
But there's still one thing you haven't let go of.
What are you talking about?
The boss.
You still haven't let her go.
The boss...
I mean...
Until they pass on...
They made up.
Depends on the ghost.
Wisp's sweating profusely.
The truth won't change the past.
You still wanna know?
No.
I took on this mission for a kid who believes in peace.
The most frustrating about this game is Snake's...
Peace Walker is on the verge of completion.
Come on boss.
Let's get to that base.
The most frustrating thing about this game...
Oh...
We got some leggies.
We got some power.
We got a lot of head.
And we got some more leggies.
Okay, back to Mother Base.
Hi Chico.
Chico, Chico, Chico.
Carl, Gustav and two.
Oh yeah, our Autoroms guy.
Delivery!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
The
flower, the flower.
Thank you for the...
Cologne.
Downgrade?
You gave me a downgrade of the curry.
Stop giving me downgrades.
Downgrade.
Remember me.
The rescue box.
Oh thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Stun box, bomb box, cardboard box.
Cardboard box, great curry.
More cologne.
What are you guys trying to say, huh?
Shield, blood box, cardboard box, more stuff.
Thank you for all the stuff everybody!
Thank you!
Special day, special day, special day, special day, special day, special day, special day, special day, special day, special day.
Yeah!
OK, let's skip the rest.
Thank you!
Did we have more guys?
We did.
We got Suni, Bullshark, Sunfish, Snipe, Capybara, Salmon, Shrimp.
Suni.
Oh, that's all of them.
I'm sorry, the POW was in the brig?
I saved your ass!
And you're gonna treat me like that?
Nice, our R&D really went up.
We have a ton of stuff that we can... Holy cow!
Stun grenade.
For sure, stun grenade.
He was in the infirmary?
Oh.
Oh yeah, also.
Fast forward.
Where's the fast forward part?
Oh, there it is.
OK.
It was fun taking down that boss at the infirmary.
I can't believe we took down the Chrysler.
Yeah!
No, he's still alive.
No!
Why did I choose the fast one?
It's so slow.
I have to keep clicking A.
This is the worst.
No way, is he the only one that doesn't make it out?
Is he the only one that doesn't make it out?
Lizard!
He's a sickbay!
I'm so worried.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so glad.
He's alive.
He just needs some smacks.
He clung on to life.
Down but not up.
Ugh.
Did...
Did YouTube break?
We're back?
What happened?
Was also YouTube so shocked about Lizard?
Don't make me worry ever again Lizard, OK?
I'm not gonna send you back out there.
Why are you sick?
Boss, that magazine I lent you before the last mission.
Can I have it?
What?
You left it out there?
I haven't finished reading it yet.
Oh, OK.
The almost loss of Lizard.
Scared me.
Scared me like nothing other.
My goodness.
I shed tears for you Lizard.
You can't leave me yet.
Hold on one second.
Return to Mother Base.
Lizard lost his tail.
How do I...
I wanna see...
I guess we have to go into the mission select.
I wanna see some of the codex, like the conversations, but...
But obviously without...
Without...
Doing the mission.
Filter them by defense or health.
I know, right?
I just sent in my worst guys.
I'll never do it again.
I'm such a fool.
It's also item capture.
Gosh.
We got classified documents.
Target demolition, Fulton recovery.
A lot of Fulton recovery.
Some of these I might actually do off stream.
I hope you guys don't mind.
You really do care for your men, don't you boss?
I do.
No...
Yeah, like some of these I can do.
No worries.
And the cutscenes we got too.
It's always fun to go back and look at.
Wait, cancel.
Saving special missions for stream is a good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I try to do anyway.
Some of these, like Fulton recovery, number 17.
There's a lot of extra ops.
But a lot of them are really good to have for some of the later on stuff.
Hold on.
I'm not gonna do this.
I'm gonna skip it.
And I'm just gonna go into the briefing files.
Oh no!
Wait!
How do you...?
There we go.
The file library.
Here we go.
About himself.
How Miller met Snake.
And now here we are fighting side by side.
Yeah, after I quit the JSDF.
I wanna hear Miller's Spanish.
Spanish.
Japan mentioned.
He sees Snake and...
His mind goes blank.
May, I'm from Japan by the way.
By the way, I'm from Japan.
Konnichiwa.
I'd heard samurai were a proud bunch.
I wanted to know why one of them would stoop so low as to try to take his opponent with him.
And I said, I'll never lose again.
We'll never lose again.
Yeah, we'll do whatever it takes, but we'll never be beaten again.
Then, I passed out from the blood loss.
When I woke up, I was in your camp's infirmary, stuck full of tubes.
Why'd you save me, your enemy, after I tried to kill you?
Because you swallowed your pride and fought with everything you had.
I just didn't want to lose.
You found a way to fight back, even in the face of death.
Even when you knew you were going to die.
That's the mark of a true warrior.
It's not about gain and loss, or victory and defeat.
I looked at the way you lived your life and saw the path I needed to take as a warrior.
Wow.
I never knew that.
And that's why you...
I realized then, that the battlefield doesn't only divide people into allies and enemies.
Sometimes, it tells you more than just who's an ally or who's an enemy.
Sometimes, it helps reveal your true comrades.
Like you and me, huh?
That's right.
And two years later, here we are.
Rolls within Mother Base.
Whatcha doin' over there, mister?
Don't forget to give the MSF staff assignments.
Where you place people will determine how Mother Base grows.
Right.
That goes for me, too.
Assign me wherever you think is best.
You?
I thought you were second in command.
Don't worry, I've got that covered.
But MSF is still small.
No, we're not!
I don't have the leisure of sitting around on my butt all day.
I see your point, but...
Not to brag or anything, but I'd kick ass at whatever job you gave me.
Put me in the area you want to focus on developing most.
I'll take real good care of the staff there.
Easy, Kaz.
I'm jealous of whoever's on Kaz's team.
The morale in Kaz's team is through the roof.
This is the best one.
Snake, about cardboard boxes...
It feels kind of weird me explaining this stuff to you, but there have been a few recent developments in cardboard box technology.
So just to be safe, here goes.
Go on.
You can do much more with a box than just hide under it.
You can put it someplace and leave it there.
You can get on top of it and use it to reach high places, or hide from the enemy in its shadow.
I like what I'm hearing so far.
And that's not all.
You can even put items in it and send them to Co-op's teammates.
Really?
I never thought of any of that.
Damn, is there anything a cardboard box can't do?
Every soldier should have one.
Yeah, well, don't get too excited.
This isn't exactly what they were made for.
Which reminds me, don't you think the boxes around here are a little on the... big side?
You're right.
I bet two people could fit under one box.
If they packed in tight enough.
They call them love boxes.
Love boxes?
Of course you don't need a love box to fit two people inside.
Any box of similar size will do.
Two men in a box...
Up to two people can fit inside a cardboard box.
Tell me how.
Tell me how!
Get close to a box with a teammate inside, and an icon will appear.
Then press the action button.
You'll stay inside as long as the action button is pressed.
So, same as snake formation?
Exactly the same.
In fact, when you put on a cardboard box, when snake in, both of you can climb inside.
A box big enough to hold me and my buddy.
These are fine times we live in, hey Kaz?
Yeah.
Sure, boss.
Two men in a box...
lol
What about himself?
How Japanese are you, huh?
Oh wait, we already did that one, obviously.
Dang.
How Japanese are you, Kazuhiro Miller?
Tell me more.
Are there any other ones that you guys wanna hear about?
Wait, where's the...
Chase visits at Hiroshima.
Why do we care?
Cecile's name.
Wait, like...
This one.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I don't know many people from France.
This is so stupid.
Is it a common name?
No, not that common.
But Wagner's second wife was named Cosima Francesca Gaetano Wagner.
Huh.
You know, Kojima is a common last name in Japan.
Kaz.
It's just funny how, you know, I'm part Japanese and Cecile's middle name is so close to Kojima.
It feels like destiny unfolding.
You think so?
Oui oui.
That's a beautiful name you have.
Cecile Kojima Kaminades.
Wait a second.
Kojima Kaminades.
Hey, that's close to...
Close to what?
Your name.
It sounds almost like the sentence...
Kojima Kaminades.
In Japanese.
And what does it mean, Sibuplay?
Well, Kami is the word for God in Japanese.
Nandesu.
It's hard to explain.
But placed after God, it would turn the sentence into...
Is God.
OK.
So?
Kojima is God.
Cecile's name is a message.
I don't believe it.
Kojima is God.
Kaz.
Oh, by the way, Cecile, I'm Japanese, Cecile, and you know...
Hello, Cecile.
My name is Kazuhiro Miller, and I'm also Japanese.
Do you know Nihongo?
Konichiwa.
I take back what I said.
What did you say about Kaz?
Kojima is God.
You can't believe it.
Guys, tell me more about Japan, please.
Cecile's whole name was a real Konami employee.
Wow.
Cecile Kojima Kaminandesu.
Kojima Kaminandesu.
Why can I hear the monkey?
Oh, Picasso!
Oh, wait.
Not Picasso.
I was thinking of...
Van Gogh.
I was going to say that guy was a weeaboo too.
Ride into Kojima.
You're a real egotistical developer.
Macarons.
Tell me, Snake.
Do you ever put sweets in your rations?
Never thought about it before.
Why?
Ah, I simply love them.
French sweets are trs delicious.
Everyone loves crepes, but there are also profiteroles, eclairs, madeleines, financiers.
Then there's tartatin, and you can't forget savarin.
Oh, and mille-feuille, crepes, blanc-mange.
You already said crepes.
Yeah, you already mentioned crepes.
Souffls, croquembouche, cannelle, florentine, queen amagne, peach melbers.
Finished.
And macarons.
Macarons.
I love those the most.
Macarons in Parisian are the best.
They are so cute and colorful, and they contain meringue.
So they melt right in your mouth.
Wow, I had no idea macarons were that popular in France, too.
What do you mean in France, too?
Macarons are those coconut-flavored cookies, right?
Excuse you?
Macarons contain almond powder, not coconuts.
Don't they have peanuts in them?
I've had them in Japan a few times.
I thought they were called macarons.
Macarons?
Some cheap imitation, I am sure.
Catherine!
French macarons have a long and distinguished history.
They date back to the 16th century, when Catherine de' Medici of Florence married into the French royal family.
The story goes that her ptissier shared the recipe after they arrived.
That is a history of over 500 years.
So, they are originally from Italy, then.
Don't macarons come from Italy, too?
Look, I do not really think...
Keep in mind, macaron is almost identical to macaroni.
Well, that settles it.
I can't believe this!
To associate macarons with macaroni?
You, Monsieur Miller, are an insensible oaf.
Hey, why am I the bad guy?
Come on, Cecile, wait!
Cecile!
I can't.
I'm actually crying.
It's so funny.
He was so mad.
He was like...
Also, don't forget that macarons sound really close to macaroni.
It's so funny.
I love Peace Walker.
Oh my gosh, there's so much gold in the...
There's so much gold in the codex.
Or in the tapes.
They're so good.
Oh my gosh.
Mimicking animal calls.
Isn't there a game like that?
I want to play it.
Alright, give it to you, Zen.
That's pretty good.
I can do others, too.
Like a sheep, a pig...
Wow.
What about a pig?
That's uncanny.
Oh, I can do a rabbit, as well.
A rabbit?
Rabbits make noises?
Certainly.
But they are very faint.
So perhaps only someone who has owned one would recognize them.
I see.
Are they all rabbit owners?
So, what do they sound like?
Listen very carefully.
Okay.
Seriously?
Rabbits sound like that?
He's laughing.
They do?
If it sounds like that, I'm dying.
Cecile, you are too good at your impressions.
What?
Oh, what?
We have to listen to this one.
Rabbit sledge.
Guys, this is so great.
You mean like everybody?
Hugh, he invented vaping!
It hurts you and those around you.
Electronic cigarettes might not seem so bad then.
Yeah, when that happens, I'll think about it.
Threw him off the rig.
It's a wonder Solid Snake didn't catch on to Master Miller being a fake in MGS1.
He went the whole game without mentioning he was Japanese.
Japanese...
I love that one too.
Oh my goodness.
There's obviously more.
But we will listen to other ones another day.
This one unlocks the...
The mission, right?
So Hughie is to blame, good to know.
Another reason to hate Hughie, yeah.
So yeah, Monster Hunter.
We can probably do that next time.
Pa is so cute.
Don't forget, she goes eventually for the bonus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm all worn out from laughing so hard.
They're too good.
It's so funny.
Between two women.
Oh gosh.
That's so funny.
We got through.
Let's see, how many did we get through?
We did Destroy the Barricade.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8...
8 missions today.
Good job team.
That was so silly and so fun.
And we started the part of why I love Peace Walker so much.
I love the stuff with the mammal pod.
Do you know that Kazuhiro Miller is half Japanese?
Oh no, wait, really?
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Thanks, Hirule.
This is so fun.
So, so, so fun.
And there's still so much more.
Next week, yeah, next week will also be Saturday.
Might go for a little bit longer next week.
Though, next week I also have a collab at night.
So I can't go too, too long.
Yeah, set your sources please about Kazuhiro Miller being half Japanese.
Next week will be Saturday.
Well, it's the week after I actually have to play in the middle of the week.
So, yeah.
I've been making my schedules in advance.
More collabs?
I have two.
Two collabs next week.
And they are... I don't know if I will do my POV for either of them.
Maybe the one at night.
Because I also have one early, early in the morning.
And they're both with a bunch of Japanese people.
Not people, but like...
They're like Japanese-focused?
Like, it's hard to explain.
I don't know a lot of people joining, so I'm nervous.
We're all down if you ever want an extra OPS grind stream.
Thanks!
Maybe as a member or something.
Yeah, instead of me playing Ground Zeroes.
Yeah, yeah.
Collab with guys.
I hate to break it to you guys, but Kazuhira Miller...
That guy was discovered in his home last week.
Act just like Kaz.
I'll be like, actually, in Japan...
Macaron is really close to macaroni.
His half-Japanese home.
That guy definitely has a tatami mat room.
He loves his culture.
Half of it.
He's really passionate.
Yeah, he sleeps on a futon.
He's like, have you guys ever tried this great thing?
It's called ramen.
It's extremely Japanese.
Yeah, this is a lot of fun.
And this game is actually quite long, so we have a lot more to get through.
But we're still making good progress.
Shocking news, Kazuhira Miller was found on his home.
No!
Do you think Kaz makes everyone in Mother Base take their boots off when they get on the helicopter boat?
Absolutely.
No, probably not on base, but definitely entering his room.
Definitely entering his room, he makes everyone take off their shoes.
Thanks for the stream, boss.
I apologize for my performance in the mission.
No!
Way better.
It was so much fun.
Thank you for joining.
Thank you, guys.
It was so much fun.
I will see you guys when I see you next.
Have a good day, have a good night.
Remember to stay loyal to the mission.
And I'll see you next.
See you guys, thank you.